- [Voiceover] Iyashi
Octopus Sucker Massage.
- Ew.
- This is a nipple sucker?
- Ew, what am I supposed to put in that?
- Maybe you should wet it.
- Yeah, if you want to
get wet, let's get wet.
- Yeah.
- Does that feel good?
- No.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Ow.
- Does it feel relaxing?
- No.
- It's really not relaxing for me though.
- It doesn't stick.
- I've never been so disappointed to have
a product not suck my skin.
- Kogao, is this like a luchador mask?
- Yeah.
- Look how little her face
if compared to my face.
- So in Japan having a smaller
face is a symbol of beauty?
- I look like I'm going to kill someone.
- Hang on, you're taking my eyeball out.
- Let me see that (laughing).
You look cute though.
- We look like the worst super heros.
- It is pulling my face back.
- I feel it working my
cheeks, my upper cheeks.
I feel like I'm pressing my head.
- This is what Botox must feel like.
- Eyelid Trainer, what?
The problem I have with this is that
it's all in Japanese
but the person on here
is a white girl.
- Is this going to like slice my eyeball?
- There's so many instructions.
Like whoa.
(laughing)
- Ow, ow, oh.
- What did it do to you?
No, now I'm scared.
- I can't see.
- There's no pressure on this.
There's no way it does anything.
This just makes me sad
that people are wasting
their money on this.
- Of all the things to (bleeping) change,
no one's paying attention to your eyelids.
- Face Slimmer Mouthpiece,
why would I want
to make my face slimmer?
- It's what a sex doll's mouth looks like.
- One, two.
- Ah.
(laughing)
- I'm starting to drool.
- Ah, oh.
- Ah, ah.
- How do you do that?
(mumbling)
(laughing)
- It hurt my lips.
- Yeah, my mouth hurts.
- I feel like it maybe
gave me Kylie Jenner lips
just by like stressing them out.
- If I did this three minutes a day
for like a week, I'd
probably get lock jaw.
- Stuff that like enforces
a certain standard
of beauty makes me uncomfortable.
- Yes, (bleeping) weird.
What people do for beauty
I don't understand.
- Just be happy with what you got.
- Yeah.
- I think this plus this is the
best Halloween costume ever.
(laughing)
- Bye.